today I am joined by former DEA Special
Agent in Charge Jack Reilly who led the
task force that captured El Chapo he
headed up both the Chicago and El Paso
DEA field offices before retiring as the
highest-ranking agent in the agency his
book his drug warrior inside the hunt
for El Chapo and the rise of America's
opioid crisis really a pleasure having
you on I appreciate it oh it's my
pleasure thank you
so I want to learn about the entire sort
of process that was taking place behind
the scenes in your work related to the
El Chapo case but I want to think about
it in the context of a lot of what's in
the news today about immigration and the
us-mexico border so maybe I'll just open
this way which is talk to us a little
bit about the ways in which your work on
the El Chapo case can inform our view on
the current immigration and border
debate well I think one of the main
things that we've developed and learn
quite frankly the hard way is for us to
be successful at any immigration
initiative it's going to take the
cooperation of the of the other country
that in this case Mexico and that has
been a real problem I think for this
country certainly in the narcotic trade
it's been a tough tough fight to gain
trust and to make them Buy in as true
partners so I think one of the things
we've learned from the Chaco
investigation is the importance of
bridge building and understanding that
you really have to enlist the help
specifically of countries that are
cartel infested and that also includes
obviously the immigration issue that's
interesting so when you hear for example
an elected official proposed some kind
of unilateral change to strategy or
tactics like for example a wall or
drones or cameras or whatever it is is
it just noticeably missing from that
that there's no consideration given to
what the other country is doing in this
particular case Mexico yeah I think
that's a big issue buy-in from from
Echo has really been the lesson that
I've learned that I think we haven't
done a very good job in terms of the
rhetoric that's been political rhetoric
that's been used and some condescending
comments made by the administration in
general about the border and more
specifically about the Mexican people
those things can really ruin
relationships that took years to
maintain and build so with the El Chapo
case the trafficking of illicit drugs
was a big factor in terms of how El
Chapo was funded the networks that he
had in many many different countries can
you talk a little bit about I mean you
were front and center in this
investigation the drugs that were being
trafficked what percentage can you even
estimate we're coming over through the
border but not through ports of entry
rather where there might be a wall if we
were to build one I would say maybe 20%
and here's how I know that through many
many investigations through the briefing
of cooperating that defendants through
informant information through working
with the Mexicans through legal
electronic surveillance where we're
actually hearing the bad guys talk to
the bad guys on both sides of the border
there's very little evidence that the
large cartels are willing to move
high-volume
amounts of drugs in desolate on wild
areas when they can it makes better
business sense for them to attack the
ports of entry where literally thousands
of cars trucks and buses and people
cross every single day was there a
particular policy and of course you were
working on this case for some long
period of time so policy shifted and
changed during that time but was there
any particular policy enacted by the
federal government that helped you in
the work you were doing on this case and
was there any federal government policy
that may be hindered or slowed down your
progress on this case I think quite
frankly the State Department was really
instrumental in what
talk about bridge building and also
establishing institutions within some of
these countries and really trying to
leverage the rule of law in favor for
our investigations and the State
Department spent I don't know what their
anti-drug budget was I know ambassador
bill brownfield who is a dear friend of
mine used to head that up and I know it
was over a billion dollars so our
ability to help them train to get them
equipment and to make them interface
with us in other countries so that we
can share intelligence information and
make kids both domestically and in
Mexico and coordinate that information I
think has been one of the real
highlights over the last 20 years so
before we get into some of the
nitty-gritty of the case because it's
it's super interesting the last sort of
pseudo political thing I wanted to ask
about was when you hear about the idea
of taking money that DoD would normally
have for use on the drug issue that you
worked on taking it and instead using
some portion of that to build a wall
does that seem like a good idea to you
not a good idea or you're unsure it
scares me quite quite frankly if you
looked at the proposal where they're
getting the money obviously it's thick
and I think a billion dollars from the
State Department's anti-narcotic efforts
and it's also taking 600 million dollars
from the drug asset forfeiture fund and
that's what really scares me because
much of what we do here domestically is
done through our task force's and that's
where we go out and this is not just DEA
it's all federal agencies we go out and
we deputize state and local policemen to
sit and work shoulder their shoulder
with us on task forces and their
overtime is paid from that fund their
training is paid from from that fund so
I haven't seen the specific chip but
that was the one thing that really
alarmed me because it's almost like
robbing Peter to pay Paul if our task
forces shrink our intelligence based
shrinks our resources to work cases
shrink and we begin to lose touch with
our state and local agencies who are
vital to everything
do I think right now the way we are yeah
I think we almost have an evil even
number of DEA special agents federal
agents and deputized task forces so you
can imagine if that I wrote it at all
it's gonna really hurt our ability to do
the job point point point taken
okay so let's talk a little bit about
your work on the case there are lots of
people who work on cases like this who
remain relatively anonymous particularly
to the people that are on the other side
of their sort of interest because you
were known as the El Paso special agent
in charge for a period of time you
weren't able to do that in other words
the adversary knew exactly who you were
was that a problem and did it become a
problem in your personal life at any
point in time well I'll tell you there
was a couple of incidents that we had in
El Paso and then when I moved on to
become the chief operations and then the
number two at the EA they taught me a
very valuable lesson the safety issue of
our agents along the border and really
all over the world it was the real thing
that kept me up at night especially as
the deputy because when you've got phone
calls in the middle of the night and
you're talking about globally it's never
good news so with the heightened
violence at the time I was in El Paso
and wire Juarez made people at that time
we're seeing it was more dangerous than
Kabul and and Baghdad it really was a
concern and we had to really take a
special special care of our civilian
employees many of which who lived right
on the board and we had several they
actually lived in water so my concern
was for their safety and certainly the
kidnapping that was going on along the
border and still in some parts of the
border today was it was a real concern
were you specifically targeted to your
knowledge at any point for your
participation in that investigation yeah
I think in 2007 when I first arrived in
El Paso and again you never really know
if these things are factual and true but
you better take him seriously if Chapo
is behind it I gave an interview to a
newspaper and what and
El Paso why ours a sister city and I
said essentially that I was there to
take out chapo and damning sin Allah as
much as I could and course that didn't
play too well with him and we found out
several days later that there had been
some information obtained from the
Mexicans where they had collected
information that he had he wanted my
head cut off for a hundred thousand
dollars so that got my attention but it
also may made me kind of feel good
because I was getting under his skin
already and and that was really the
intention huh
were you offended that it was only a
hundred thousand dollars well that was
that was the biggest joke in the agency
as like my wife said my god you gotta be
worth more in the heart the trouble he
caused me so yeah that was I mean that
was that was if you can laugh in a bad
time we were laughing so we know that
one of his escapes was aided and abetted
by people within the Mexican government
you can sort of discuss exactly how high
up it went how does that relate to when
you're working the case you know that
that's a possibility that I guess it's
hypothetically possible that some of the
people you believe are working with you
on the Mexican side may actually be in
the in the pocket or in the employ of
the person that you are you are going
after how do you deal with that well I
can tell you for us it was a struggle
10-15 years ago when we would share
information with our counterparts in
Mexico it was nerve-racking because much
of it was compromised or they never did
anything about it but when we began
working on the chapel investigation
early on and we were allowed to work
with the Mexican Marines by the way I
think our heroes the whole the whole
landscape changed and we felt we had a
trustworthy partner and indeed if it had
to been for the Marines working with us
we would have never captured him twice
and certainly wouldn't have been able to
extradite him to the United States where
he's sitting in a Cell not too far from
me one of the interesting things in your
book is you talk about the role that the
el chapo led cartel played in the opioid
crisis in
United States and even just more broadly
in in the trade of illicit drugs can you
talk a little bit about the role that
the war on drugs as executed with the
criminalization that we have on many
drugs and in many parts of the United
States how much of a role does that play
in the creating the environment that
sort of creates a market for these types
of transnational cartels yeah that's
definitely and you hear about it every
day the appetite of the American drug
culture is without violence and that is
certainly an issue but I think one thing
that we really have to take a look at in
this particular situation is I think
Sinaloa and chapo and the way that he
built it and ran it I really do believe
it is the most well financed vicious
criminal entity the world's ever known
so we were up against something that
we'd never seen before
Chapo's tentacles until a Mexican
government in terms of corruption were
virtually in every corner of the
government and he'd been doing that for
20 years which is important because that
means he made it through presidential
transitions and was able to maintain
power his vicious lure everyone knows
about it but he was very smart about the
way he used it he understood that
violence and the threat of violence is
important to keeping your rivals at bay
but to overuse violence specifically
here in the United States or on the US
side of the border is just bad for
business so his business model really
was to cater to the needs of the
American people I believe at the time I
was the head of the Chicago office where
prescription drugs was really becoming
an issue and obviously leading the
opioid dependence we know that chap was
slowed down his importation of cocaine
and sped up and spent enormous resources
to produce more poppies in Mexico so he
saw the market turning and what he did
was I think unfortunately he's a mass
murderer no question about it he's one
hell of a corporate CEO what he did was
he saw the market and he changed his
business model to meet the market so he
began flooding the US
with cheap high potency heroin and this
was different heroin because it was
being smoked and snorted there wasn't a
needle there wasn't the fear of AIDS or
hepatitis so it attracted a completely
different user base you know on down to
our high schools and professional adults
almost glamourizing it as a weekend drug
but what was really important was at
that point the opioid crisis took over
and eventually your doctor stops writing
prescription the pharmacist won't give
it to you difficult difficult to get on
the street you can't get it out of your
grandmother's medicine cabinet anymore
because it's gone so what do you do well
you gotta walk that dark road to buying
heroin in Chicago choppa was brilliant
because he used nearly a hundred
thousand street gang members really is
his co-conspirators his unwitting
salesmen if you will who put the dope on
the street and collected money and he
could care less who they kill as they
did their business so when I look at
chapo and Sinaloa I I've never seen
anything as corporately organized now
chapo also and it's part of his downfall
he was a master manipulator
he was extremely paranoid very paranoid
about telecommunications and he was just
a taskmaster he was way too micromanager
he was involved in things he should have
never been involved in in terms of
negotiating things and putting him and
his organization in harm's way and that
was one of the reasons why we were able
to really indict him in eight or nine
jurisdiction here in the United States
and then bring it all together for the
trial here in New York at the level of
the DEA at which you operated
particularly towards the end of your
career were their candid discussions
between you and colleagues where you
would say you know we we might solve a
lot of problems if we legalized cannabis
I know I mean that's not to say that
people weren't thinking that especially
under the Obama administration where you
began seeing the state's you know
exploring and taking responsibility for
but I was a cop I wasn't a politician in
my last
two years there I spent a tremendous
amount of time testifying in front of
Congress and working on the bill with
senators and staffers and congressmen
and it was extremely frustrating because
I heard from them why don't you just
forget marijuana just abandon it you
know and go after the hard drugs well
the problem was and I used to get
people's upset so there's a cop you make
the laws if you tell us today DEA you're
responsible for arresting people that
sell widgets well that's what I'm gonna
do but if you're asking me as if there's
a cop to make these decisions not only
in that qualified DEA is not qualified
to do it it's based off the science so
everyone blames the EEA saying well they
won't you know marijuana still scheduled
water it's not us it's the FDA it's the
scientists that say there's no human use
for medical use for so I think there's
so much misinformation and there's a the
lobbying groups for legalization and I
think very effective and certainly the
men bankrolled by some billionaire so
this is a tough problem we're facing now
and one of the reasons I didn't want to
write the book to be honest with you but
one of the reasons I wanted to write it
was to try to kind of explain how we got
here yeah and the and the people in
which we have to deal with that are
terrible and if we don't deal with them
if we don't maintain a strong robust
international law enforcement presence
this is going to lead to something other
than their cops
imagine if chapo had joined with some
type of a terrorist organization with
disability and is calling across the
border it would have been it could have
been terrible for us so that's what I'm
concerned about and I think as we move
forward and we deal with this issue both
domestically and internationally we got
keep that in the back of our mind the
book is called a drug warrior inside the
hunt for El Chapo and the rise of
America's opioid crisis we've been
speaking with former DEA Special Agent
in Charge Jack Riley Jack really a
pleasure speaking to you today it was a
pleasure for me to thank you and I think
you guys did great work